les forces de l'ordre totalement
mobilisés en cette crise sanitaire du
colis de 19 notamment avec des policiers
des gendarmes directement au contact de
la population lors des contrôles des
attestations de déplacement dérogatoire
les policiers qui sont notamment
inquiets en cette période on va en
parler avec julien le cam
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le secrétaire
régional d'alliance police nationale
dans les yvelines
alors nos confrères du parisien relatait
dans leur édition du week-end une
situation chaotique pour les policiers
dans les yvelines ya près d'un millier
de policiers qui seraient indisponibles
dans le département selon plusieurs
syndicats est ce que c'est une situation
que vous confirmez la situation est très
difficile aujourd'hui pour les policiers
dans les yvelines alors en fait le
fonctionnement est particulier en ce
moment des des commissariats on se
concentre sur l'urgence les
interventions urgentes et notamment les
aussi les contrôles de des différentes
attestations on monte les points de
contrôle alors c'est pas tout à fait
mille fonctionnaires hors service
il faut savoir que parmi ces mille
fonctionnaires et en a quasiment 700 qui
sont ce qu'on appelle en réserve
c'est à dire c'est les fonctionnaires
qui sont à domicile 1 et qui seront
utilisées donc en remplacement des
fonctionnaires et potentiellement
touchées par une maladie il y a à peu
près 300 fonctionnaires par contre en
arrêt maladie sur le département et qui
pour l'instant n'impacte pas le
fonctionnement
ce qu'on appelle en mode dégradé des
commissariats donc en arrêt maladie ils
sont ils ont été testés positifs au
coronavirus papa que alors pas tous
malheureusement défaut de test lassé des
fonctionnaires qui sont placés en arrêt
maladie par leur médecin traitant
1 puisqu'ils présentent des symptômes
donc par précaution c'est les
fonctionnaires qui sont placés en arrêt
maladie
est ce que le quel est l'état du moral
on imagine que c'est un moral qui est
qui n'est pas au beau fixe aujourd'hui
non du tout il faut savoir que mes
collègues justement le moral bas on le
voit les carences de l'administration et
de l'état mais faut il aimer mes
collègues ont fait face au début donc dû
justement du confinement a aucun
matériel de protection dont il était
très difficile pour eux justement de
procéder au contrôle des attestations en
respectant les gestes barrière c'est
très difficile
il faut savoir que vous avez des
secteurs 1 les personnes ne respectent
pas un tout de suite je vous avez un
contact vous avez une discussion un peu
virulente et mes collègues n'ont pas de
masque et ni de gants etc ce qui
forcément créer un vin a un gros
problème chez nous c'est ce manque de
considération et ce manque de matériel
donc un manque de matériel et aussi
parfois en certaines zones des yvelines
quelques quelques soucis rencontrés par
par vos collègues il ya eu quelques
quelques agressions quelques insultes
aussi qui ont été proférées à l'encontre
des policiers
ah bah il faut savoir que ce que vous
vivez ce que l'on vit depuis des années
c'est à dire ceux voilà ce sentiment on
va dire de laxisme de la justice qui est
en fait durant confinement qui ne
s'arrête pas il faut savoir que pour
procéder à des contrôles d'identité ou
des contrôles pas d'attestation c'est
toujours très difficile vous avez des
individus qui n'acceptent pas ce
contrôle qui n'acceptent pas ce
confinement notamment dans les quartiers
difficiles à on voit mes collègues à
trappes qui ont été carrément agresser
lors d'un contrôle d'attestation on a
trois collègues qui avaient été blessés
à ce moment là il faut savoir que les
individus ne s'arrête pas au confinement
ni à une pandémie
1 nous avons malheureusement laissé sa
ces individus ce sentiment d'impunité
continue malgré de confinement est donc
vous parler on va terminer avec ceux de
ce manque de protection je crois que ce
sont 300 mille masques qui était attendu
au niveau national aujourd'hui il ya des
distributions qui était prévue cet après
midi dans les yvelines ce ça alors notre
syndicat alliance police nationale a
récupéré un stock via une grande
enseigne de vêtements un stock de douze
mille masques donc cet après midi je
vais récupérer deux mille masques pour
les policiers yvelinois que j'irai
remettre à la ddsp à la direction
départementale pour une distribution
rapide dans les services parce qu'il
faut savoir que malheureusement au
niveau national nous devons nous battre
avec peu de moyens et justement notre
organisation met tout en oeuvre pour
récupérer appel aux dons et nous
procédons donc à des distributions pour
pallier aux manquements de
l'administration et de l'état donc vous
attendre c'est d'en avoir encore plus là
s'essouffle
il aujourd'hui mais c'est d'en avoir
plus pour les prochains jours oui le
syndicat alliance police nationale notre
bureau national met tout en oeuvre pour
récupérer au maximum auprès de sociétés
privées auprès de l'ue conseil général
auprès du conseil départemental ont fait
des appels aux dons
et nous irons remettre ses moyens
directement policiers merci julien
locales d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes le secrétaire
régional d'alliance police nationale
dans les yvelines